[Music]
tell me a little bit about this day that
we are crashing I am so excited to be
shooting a WWD cover I think it's the
authority in beauty business and I'm so
honored I'm so honored to be shooting
today ET catching up with kim k behind
the scenes of her Women's Wear Daily
cover shoot talking her new fragrance
her partnership with the app screen shop
and family not only is business growing
family is growing too so congratulations
you know what has been the adjustment
sort of going through this with a
surrogate this time you know it's really
different anyone that says or thinks
it's just the easy way out is completely
wrong yeah I think it's so much harder
to go through it this way because you're
not really in control and you know
obviously you pick someone that you
completely trust and that you have a
really good bond and relationship with
but it's still knowing that I was able
to carry my first two babies and not you
know my baby now that is hard for me so
it's definitely a harder experience than
I anticipated just in the control area
right I hated being pregnant and I never
thought I'd ever I thought this was
gonna be so easy and you know but I
still even in how much I hated it if I
could do it myself I would have
preferred that so that's a little like
that inner struggle is kind of hard but
I'm just rolling with it and it's still
a process that you have to really digest
it's still you know figuring out which
I'm pretty I'm really honest with my
kids but even just answering the
questions and even the fact that it's
happening and you do forget sometimes
because I think when you are pregnant by
the time you have the baby you're so
prepared and so ready and now I'm just
like oh my god I'm gonna freak out
because I'm not ready and I'm not
prepared but it'll just all come into
place are the kids excited they are
excited I mean I don't know if they
don't feel it as much because I don't
they don't see my big belly and
probably hear me complaining every two
seconds so though but we do talk about
it a lot so they will I think they're
really excited I think my son I don't
know how he's gonna react because he
doesn't get it yet but my daughter's
really excited